basically this is covering like the age
Gap type of topic I personally don't
think that it comes to intentions now
this is a big part of it like some
people come to talk to younger female
because it's easier to kind of get
something out of them because there is
that sense of them being naive because
they're kind of new to the world but I
also don't think it's a bad thing
because I feel like a lot of you know
girls want stability and like a serious
relationship and the likelihood of a guy
around the same age as you wanting that
is very unlikely realistically and I
feel like older men
who have already experienced it and
almost like kind of had their fun who
are actually looking to settle down are
more likely to give you what you want so
if it's coming from a perspective where
it's not a form of just trying to like
take an advantage of someone being young
then I don't see the problem with it
okay so you don't have a problem with
what he said like he prefers younger
girls because they've slept with lots of
people by and large you see now if you
see how he's worded it out I feel like
like he's like everyone said the
delivery I feel like it's a bit of Click
bait and it's exaggerated and it is a
bit
um I mean there's nothing wrong to want
to be with somebody who slept with less
people like I think that's a that's a
valid reason so you know I can't really
speak against on I don't think he said
anything wrong specifically here okay
here we go this is like Andrew we want
to love you so bad the thing he does is
like he'll say everything for me was
fine until he did the empress I didn't
print thing and I think that's what a
lot of people latched on to where it's
like okay the 18 19 year old that's a
whatever thing but when you say imprint
it almost sounds very predatory so like
I generally agree with what he's saying
less people you've been with the less
complications like everyone has baggage
but we're trying to eliminate that I
agree with it but when he says the
imprint thing then I see the world go
crazy and I get it so I want to be on
his side on this one but that one yeah
what's wrong with imprint I think it
just has a negative connotation of like
grooming and like you know how was that
I think I think of Twilight
yes yes that was kind of fun so I mean I
think that's just like if if we have no
issue with grooming then that wouldn't
be a problem but people generally have
an issue with grooming
so I don't understand how imprint and
grooming because what I when I think of
maybe I just think of the term different
I just think of imprint as like the guy
that made the most of like an impact
that you saw like because I think of
like when the term in the man atmosphere
is Alpha Widow and so like that's what I
think of when I think of imprint and
that's like that's the ambiguity of it
like yeah you can think that way and
that's and that's how I thought of it
first but then I've heard people speak
about it and like I hear I can see where
they're coming from like what what do
they think it is they're seeing it as a
grooming fashion like like when you say
imprint it's like I want to like this is
this is my girl like she likes this
because I've told her to like this like
it's like I'm imprinting whatever right
but couldn't you do that at like 22 too
you could but it just goes back to the
predatory nature of like someone who's
18. like if you said I want to date a 30
year old because I can put my imprint I
don't think anyone would be crazy about
it but he says like 18 which is already
young and it has all that connotation so
I just think that's why people have an
issue with it but for me everything you
set up to that like makes logical sense
to me but okay uh why don't you go next
um I don't think like he's he's
obviously not actually saying oh I'm
gonna go out and date an 18 or 19 year
old he has made a very good point that
you know the majority of younger people
haven't slept with as many people but I
know when when when you're that sort of
age or you're like School leave at age
all people talk about is how many people
you've slept with all of this and it's
the bigger the number that is the better
when you get older you realize actually
it's the opposite the lower number of
people is better like and I know that
for example I know I'm an exception
because I've been with two people and
I'm 24 and I know that a lot of people
my age would not be like that
and obviously that that's fine and
that's their choices but
I don't think he's saying anything
negative the age Gap isn't necessarily a
problem and the word imprint I I again
like I would say my partner has had an
imprint on me because he's impacted me
as a person I don't think that that is a
negative way I think it's his Persona
and the way that he portrays himself and
because he is looking for that sort of
entertainment factor and more views he's
gonna try and come across as a bit more
of an [ __ ] because more people are
going to talk about him okay and then
you and then you guys can go again yeah
although what he says comes across
extreme is again generally what people
think but behind closed doors so it's
taboo only on that basis people don't
speak their mind because they have to be
politically correct so I feel what he's
stating here is that a man of his
caliber once I have an imprint not
owning or anything negatory of that
sense but he wants to let a late a woman
know what he's like like for example um
I was dating a woman who had
she she made an order from boohoo sorry
if I can say that and this dress was
tight sorry
it was tight it was tight to the breast
tight to the booty and we're going on
holiday together and I said straight
away look I'm not trying to control what
you do you got a choice but honestly I
wouldn't feel comfortable if you're
wearing that because you're walking with
me and I respect you and I feel that
will be a little bit of a disrespect to
me so I I was a bit marginal how I
presented that I wouldn't be like
agitate stating things but I do
understand his concept that he's
preaching on those kind of bases but
he's just being extreme about it but is
there a difference between an impact and
an imprint nothing words matter like if
you're gonna say I want someone I can
make an impact
I think there's a difference like one
sexual one's not like my dad can have an
impact on me yeah but I would I feel
like if I said imprint that'd be weird
right
sample and something like a cow so that
is
an ownership so that's like like you do
as I say but an impact that can be
positive like on your mindset I'd like
to think of it as that if you said
impact I don't think that would have had
an issue do you agree with the imprint
part or not almost I I still do because
I I like to think I'm a positive person
so if I imprint you of me being positive
there's nothing it depends on your
intention if we want to go back to that
again even though you just compared it
to branding a cow that's it that's if
it's negative but okay if I brand new as
a cow and it's positive and from that
moment onwards you're like oh I like
that stamp I got from him yeah
I'll Implement as many people as I can
but I understand terminology is
important but I feel like we as a
society we look at things so detailed we
lose the point of what we're actually
trying to make it's like oh no that's
too negative to say that and then we
just focus on those things as opposed to
the whole message I think with Andrew
Tate as well like he's everywhere in the
media and everyone is trying to find
more negative things about him at the
moment so they're picking out that one
word just on that clip just because they
want to try and make it more horrendous
well and you can see more horrendous and
the thing is there's someone like I talk
on the internet people can clip
something and take you out of context
and you'll be in like a two-hour
interview and they take a 15 second clip
they don't watch the full interview and
then they make an assumption about what
you said but in the interview you give a
lot more context and clarification and
where a majority of his Clips came on
Tick Tock yeah their Clips like they're
not the full interview right and what do
you guys think go ahead
me personally when I watched that clip
it's
I personally it does sound manipulating
it really does I don't know how old
Andrew tank is but I'm guessing in his
30s for me 40s for me personally what
would a man in his 40s want with a 19
year old
everyone says he's like 40 years 30s or
40. my purse opinion what would a man in
his 30s or 40s want with five thirty
five what would a man who's 35 want with
a 19 year old